i'm elegance bratton i'm the winner of  the true  fiction award presented by genesis my  film is called peer kids  it follows three queer trans black  homeless youth  who use christopher street as a location  to build  new chosen families i spent 10 years of  my life homeless  after my mother kicked me out for being  gay now that i've gone through the  process of making this film  and i've had an institution like film  independence support  me making this film and make sure that  the industry knows this film matters  i just have a lot more belief in myself  and i'm even more emboldened  in my mission to bring stories to screen  of  my experience thank you genesis thank  you film independent